this is an investigation this isn't
deduction nervous louder it ain't I got
it he did it
hi I'm John I'm a private investigator
been doing this for about three years
I've been involved in a lot of big cases
major cases criminal civil you name it
I've seen it it's a dark world out there
and today I'm going to try and deduce
who ate my sandwich i Blake been too
long my friend there's some mold on this
bread sandwich all right well you and I
know each other right yeah okay why
don't you come join me how are you I'm
good how are you I'm fine
tell me your name again Becky Becky I
know where your work and I know what you
do well that's good we're different
wreckfish today coffee with what
sweetened condensed milk is that better
than it's the best you should try it
why because it adds a little sweetness
it makes your coffee extra creamy so no
solid food today for you not yet
besides your lunch of course another
game begins you know people who haven't
eaten my lunch say they ate my lunch
people who have eaten my lunch say they
ate my lunch just to throw me off really
we get into the showdown here the mental
chess match this is an investigation
this isn't deduction this is a circus
trick and I'm the elephants where you
live Hollywood all right you live in
Hollywood were you from originally
Phoenix oh yes okay what's your favorite
sandwich grilled cheese warm preferably
cold grilled cheese doesn't quite have
the same nope I was gonna talk about
consistency
you said melts factors yeah yeah there's
a creaminess to grilled cheese there's a
theme here I like creamy foods creamy
car I'm the detective just trying to
help allow me to shine here a little bit
yeah I was gonna notice that yeah you
see you you like a certain mouthfeel
yeah it is so far in your comfort what's
your favorite dessert ice cream favorite
flavor of ice cream Oh vanilla why is
that weird you can do anything with it
it's endless possibilities so you dress
it up yeah
with what sometimes chocolate syrup
sometimes
cayenne pepper Kanye sometimes Kanye
West iron pepper cayenne pepper
preferably that's not weird it's unusual
look I'm not here to invite you out for
dessert valid I'm also not here at cast
judgment so I shouldn't say the word
weird but it's unusual cayenne pepper
mm-hmm I was I thought I was pushing
boundaries when I was gonna ask you if
you've ever done like honey roasted
peanuts oh I'm not a big peanut man
because of the consistency they're a
little crunchy for my taste it's true
mm-hmm not a fan of peanuts this is
creamy peanut butter though okay where'd
you go to college Arizona State yeah I
know you you went to grad or law school
yes can we say that where'd you go to
law school
southwestern where's that okay it's on
the edge of downtown LA okay I think I'm
done for now Becky thank you for your
time
anytime I'm always here if you need me
would you join me please what's your
name
where's Matt where you from I'm from
Southern California okay well part chino
hills' it's near like the Pomona area oh
god yeah so Greater Los Angeles metro
area I do yeah a little bit outside no
yeah where you live now Studio City okay
what do you do for a living I'm working
post Brown we're here what's your
favorite sandwich like ham pretty simple
about ham what about pastrami
huh yeah it's good to supposed to meet
some finally okay anything or not
finally I mean it's Ricky hey hey tricky
but it's a little bit I'd prefer not to
have it so you like some maybe some of
the more salted cured meats yeah
somewhere on the salami spectrum yeah is
that like an official like things like
Scoville units we're taking known like
food thing probably not know it should
be maybe BuzzFeed can give me a new
spinoff series where I talk about
sandwich meats I'd watch it alright so
you're a ham man not exactly anti Turkey
but not exactly by being Turkey
yeah which frankly what do you put on
your sandwiches tomatoes olives
cucumbers not a whole lot like Irish you
don't have like condiments or anything
like that interesting no mustard or I
like Buster no is that shocking I love
mustard I'm sorry to sort of do this
okay it's not weird
it's unusual okay okay well I'm gonna
offend you by asking about mayonnaise
cuz well let's just
let's forget I even brought it up okay
so but interesting so olives and
cucumbers that actually sounds pretty
incredible a ham sandwich with olives
cucumbers and tomato that sounds
interesting
yeah which if you're a movie star wars
episode 4 mm-hmm okay what's your
favorite comedy Star Wars Episode one
right mm-hmm
wait top five so I say stars number one
the group Star Wars the franchise
because I'm trying more people in Star
Wars movies like The Dark Knight
inception or II like Christopher Nolan
if that's 3d oh no on the clown movies
okay how long it was in Studio City
um about like eight months okay would
you have a breakfast cereal a second
Cheerios we're at my place kind of milk
geez it's 2% what's that face mist it
wasn't sweet and condensed you drink
coffee I do not
that's good you drink tea not really so
you have no morning beverage routine I'm
mostly drink water
I guess that's healthy all right now I
think I'm good for now with you thank
you for your time wonderful talk why
don't you join me please what's your
name Austin Austin hi little did you eat
that yeah that's pretty hungry where you
from
I'd say Torrance Cardenas where do you
live now crunch oh okay like south of
the 10 yeah West Adams yeah he I'm in
the area okay
hauling a litter about a year and a half
almost two years actually okay what do
you do for a living
I am the case assistant I work part-time
at a law firm well offload a Bowman
anymore are they downtown no they're
actually in Torrance okay what's their
break room like it's got a coffee
machine couple sinks usually gonna go
out there that often on to say even my
desk al I pack a lunch
yeah would eat sometimes chinese food
pizza whatever is left over which is
very dessert mmm
mochi what's mochi it's like a pounded
rice cake usually I like the really
sweet and kind I've heard of it I don't
know what it is yeah it's like if you
imagine like a fruits net a large fruit
snack made out of rice instead but it
doesn't even taste like rice I'm sorry a
fruit snack made out of your rice kind
of like like a consistency and chewiness
wild what's your favorite movie what's
your favorite TV show
oh the good place right now that's funny
as hell right everyone's just funny okay
who's your favorite actor one of them is
Alan Arkin song recently in there
Allen artment the old man the the the
patriarch of the Arkans yeah I think so
yeah
interesting alan arkin nice what's your
favorite fruit peaches go for a peach
all right Austin I think I'm done for
now thank you for your time thank you
thank you for the education on mochi oh
yes to keep it centered all right Blake
right yep we're from Seattle Washington
no oh shoot I got my tattoo and yeah
yeah you got off using old videos if I
may do it I do it hey that's case work
man and now Blake I almost wrote down
Brett I'm sorry a little town outside
Houston Bulger did you go to undergrad
oh yeah I was like you made yeah I am
sorry yeah I went to a nervous router it
ain't it I got it he did it
what a.m. and you've aged Texas A&M yeah
okay and that universities yeah that's
your favorite food like a hamburger or
something a good hamburger like a
cookout hamburgers probably the best
cheese yeah definitely she definitely
cheese doesn't she's a little a little
layer of lettuce make some pickles
ketchup only ketchup in it ah no mustard
no mustard but no mustard on anything
ever anti muster anti mustard completely
alright disagree but gotta respect it
this is America yeah let me ask you this
do you toast the bun I mean if it's you
here cook up you're making it yep that's
never really been my thing you don't you
don't toasted take the time I mean a
little a little bit especially do you do
a sesame seed bun or do you do like a
no-no sesame seeds I guess if I had a
choice I'd probably pick sesame seed
because like you like when you toss a
sesame seed buns it gets weird I feel
like it's necessary it's like a little a
little toastiness fine but then not many
people know how to actually I don't know
however you toasted your sandwich though
it's fantastic
did you make this good misdirect does it
look like I made that I just I want the
recipe it's really good what's your
favorite movie
I'm actually gonna have to go with my
cousin Vinnie I haven't seen it actually
you've never seen my cousin Vinnie no
you're totally missing yeah that's what
I hear that that one's for me
your dessert I'm not really a dessert
person I like candy and stuff I don't
like like pastries all the time so I
don't really go to serve but I would say
probably just like a red velvet cake or
something
okay what's favorite candy well it used
to be called shock tarts but now they're
called sweet sweet tart sour shoes I
don't know why they change that but it's
just rebranded Shakhtar's yeah probably
after the Iraq war let you have that one
to go with this actually I don't know
food movies another legitimate
investigative tactics could I use here
give me food allergies you know what I
didn't think I did for the longest time
and then I can move to your year ago and
I'm Drive I was getting like you know
roadtrip food and I got a box and nerds
which is another type of candy I love
and I started breaking out in hives from
the nerd from the nerd so what are you
allergic to the sugar I don't know I
think it must be a dye or so yeah
something they are with yet really it's
just it's nothing but sugar there's
another there's no style there's there's
no identity to nerds it's just the
scraps that they scrape off the floor of
the factory I love around the box yeah I
mean it's like a childhood thing yeah
okay like I think I'm good for now thank
you
there's only four so Matt and Blake both
are strongly anti mustard which doesn't
really matter but I find interesting
I got me honest I like math I love his
opinions on sandwich meat and as far as
sandwich dressings he's given me
something to really think about he works
in post-production can't trust him
Austin works for a law firm he's got to
keep his nose clean
then again clean-cut Pleasant unassuming
those are the sociopaths still don't
know what the hell moki are Blake I mean
blinded by my heart here I want to
believe that Blake wouldn't do that to
his boy but he's ruthless ma'am those
Texans they take what they want I can't
draw much information off of this byte
Becky she's a lawyer so she would know
how to obfuscate the truth also went to
ASU obviously hedonist
when I write down hedonist Becky would
you join me again how come you never ask
me what my favorite movie is what is
your favorite movie either Who Framed
Roger Rabbit or Empire Records okay any
other questions you'd like me to ask you
know I just felt excluded okay
I think in the past I've asked you who
your favorite band is or I know we've
talked about music we've talked about
music you've asked me who I've seen but
never who my favorite band oh who is
your favorite band that's a complicated
question do you have any allergies
I mean in general yeah but mostly to
like environmental stuff yeah yeah okay
how long you live in California seven
and a half years
how could you went to school out here G
right okay how long have you worked for
BuzzFeed two and a half years okay do
you work on site here yeah okay very
good Jam to peanutbutter ratio needs
more ham also if you were curious I like
mustard okay see your hands I think I
got all I need
thank you all right look I don't know
okay I have a couple suspicions
the questions were useless it was nice
to get to know these people I mean my
reputations on the line you know I see I
see the YouTube comments I know what
people expect out of me they think I'm
this you know genius that just is never
wrong that's a lot of pressure I'm a
great man I do a lot of great things but
I'm not perfect but I think maybe Becky
ate my sandwich
I definitely ate your sandwich of course
you did I am so sorry for you but anyway
congratulations you had me you've got
the eyes of a panther it's tough it's
tough to face you down down here in the
trenches it's difficult for fine frankly
it's terrifying I mean the big thing is
I mean it's not a big thing it's
meaningless but it was the only thing I
kind of latched on to is that Becky kept
talking about things that were like
creamy or sort of like savory she struck
me as a type of person who would enjoy
what appears to be a non crunchy peanut
butter peanut butter and jelly sandwich
believe it or not I really was trying to
pull some sort of evidence off of this
bite mark I was looking for lipstick I
lied about the mold because I wanted to
see anybody's reaction there was no
reaction you've all got great poker
faces you know look I'm not a forensic
pathologist but I was trying to get a
look at everybody's mouth and how their
teeth were shaped and not only overbite
versus under bite or let you know how
their teeth matched up but also how
their teeth were like a raid you know in
a certain way and this is almost a
perfect anyway I guess I know the shape
of Becky's mouth because I that that was
one of my major influencers as well ya
know it's a good mouth but uh yeah it's
a it's a telltale giveaway or maybe I'm
just that good I don't know but that's I
was thinking it was hard look at the
toss up man it's a one-off or toss up
but I got it I got it right I was right
[Applause]
[Music]